l'état monsieur eric ciotti merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
notre pays traverse une des pires
épreuves de son histoire
cette épreuve appelle de notre part de
votre part celle du gouvernement celle
de la représentation nationale
un devoir le devoir d'apporter une
réponse efficace
ce devoir nous le devons aux victimes
aux blessés
pour lesquelles j'ai une pensée nous le
devons aux forces de l'ordre qui ce
matin ont été encore une fois admirable
face aux barbares auxquelles elles ont
donné l'assaut vous avez apporté et
décider des mesures précises
ces mesures nous les soutenons et nous
les soutiendrons nous les soutiendrons
d'autant plus qu'elles répondent pour
beaucoup à des propositions que nous
avions formulées
parmi ces mesures il y à leur tour du
contrôle aux frontières
c'est un point extrêmement important
ce contrôle aux frontières aujourd'hui
ce rétablissement du contrôle frontières
se heurte à beaucoup de problèmes à
beaucoup de difficultés qui font qu'il
est plus virtuels que réels des
problèmes matériels naturellement je
prends l'exemple à la frontière
franco-italienne une voiture sur 10 en
moyenne et contrôler des problèmes
juridiques avec l'absence de pnr mais
aussi des problèmes humains avec
l'arrivée massive au cours des derniers
mois deux personnes en situation
illégale ou légale sans aucun contrôle
venant des théâtres de guerre
donc monsieur le premier ministre mais
question seront simples ou aneto enfin
de ce pnr dont on parle depuis tant
d'années où en sommes nous de la
solidarité européenne pour ce contrôle
aux frontières après ce qui a été
demandé hier à l'europe est en fait vous
prie monsieur le premier ministre à
prendre un moratoire compte tenu de la
situation de crise quant à l'arrivée de
nouveaux migrants dans notre pays
la parole et comme monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur comme
vous le savez monsieur le député ciotti
j'ai demandé
dimanche qu'il y ait une réunion
extraordinaire des ministres de
l'intérieur qui se tiendra vendredi à
bruxelles
cette réunion j'ai souhaité que l un
ordre du jour extrêmement précis premier
point le pnr européen ce pnr européen et
sur le métier depuis de nombreuses
années il est désormais dans ce que l'on
appelle le trilogue c'est à dire la
discussion entre le parlement européen
la commission européenne et le conseil
mais ce pnr européen pour être efficace
doit traiter de tous les sujets dont
nous avons besoin pour assurer la
traçabilité du retour des terroristes
sur le territoire européen et notamment
il doit prendre en compte les vols intra
communautaires et doit concerner des
personnes qui sont associées aux
organisations terroristes mais aussi un
certain nombre d'organisations
criminelles
compte tenu de la porosité qui existe
entre les acteurs du banditisme du
trafic de stupéfiants et de la drogue
c'est la raison pour laquelle vendredi
nous demanderons qu'il y ait un accord
entre les trois institutions européennes
autour des objectifs que je viens
d'indiquer deuxièmement la france a
demandé depuis août 2014 et la
proposition qu'il avait faite le 30 août
2014 à mes homologues de l'union
européenne qu' il y ait des contrôles
systématiques et coordonnée dès à
présent aux frontières de l'union
européenne on n'a pas besoin de modifier
le code schengen pour cela mais je pense
qu'il faut aller plus loin il faut pas
simplement des contrôles systématiques
et coordonnée il faut aussi des
contrôles obligatoires et il faut que
l'union européenne l'intègre le
comprennent car il ya trop
d'atermoiements sur ce sujet enfin
troisièmement j'ai souhaité qu'il y ait
une grande action autour du trafic
d'armes là aussi à une directive qui est
sur le métier depuis de nombreux mois
elle doit désormais aboutir et au
conseil j'aille de vendredi nous serons
sur ces sujets inflexible